From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 2017, Oliver Herrera made a rookie mistake. He works for the United Nations, and he just arrived at a refugee settlement in Angola in southern Africa. For the first few weeks he was there, Oliver went to sleep at night without a bednette. Bednets are a must to protect against mosquito bites and malaria. About a month into a stay, Oliver came down with a fever. I felt quite weak. He urgently needed to see a doctor. His organization arranged for a driver to take him to a local clinic.
来自NPR，这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。2017年，奥利弗·埃雷拉犯了一个新手错误。他在联合国工作，刚抵达非洲南部安哥拉的一个难民定居点。在他到那里的头几个星期里，奥利弗晚上睡觉时没有挂蚊帐。蚊帐是防范蚊虫叮咬和疟疾的必需品。大约住了一个月后，奥利弗发烧了。我感到非常虚弱。他急需看医生。他的组织安排了一名司机带他去当地诊所。
When he got there, his heart sank. There were dozens and dozens of people outside the clinic. Some of them carrying kids, some of them sitting down on the ground. The lines stretched outside the clinic, down the block. But Oliver didn't join the queue. I cannot recall if the driver had a conversation with the nurse, but what I know is that I just walked me into the clinic and I just sat down to wait for the blood test. As dozens of other sick people waited their turn, Oliver saw a doctor within minutes. He got tested. He discovered that
当他到达那里时，他的心沉了下去。诊所外面有几十甚至上百人。有些人抱着孩子，有些人坐在地上。队伍从诊所一直排到街区外。但奥利弗并没有排队。我不记得司机是否和护士交谈过，但我所知道的是，我径直走进了诊所，然后坐下来等待验血。就在几十个其他生病的等待轮候的人面前，奥利弗在几分钟内就见到了医生。他接受了检查。他发现
he did have malaria. He was flown to another city for treatment. Looking back, Oliver doesn't feel relieved that he got the care he needed. He feels something else. I felt guilty and I still am guilty. I Believe that everyone's equal. No one should have privileges just because of the way they look or because Power they have or the money they have I feel guilty because I know that I'm not better than anyone else, so I should have received the same treatment as anyone else. This week on Hidden Brain, we ask what it would mean to take Oliver's principle that all suffering should count the same and actually put it into practice.
他确实得了疟疾。他被空运到另一个城市接受治疗。回想起来，奥利弗并没有因为得到了所需的治疗而感到轻松。他感受到了别的东西。我感到内疚，现在依然感到内疚。我相信人人平等。任何人都不应该仅仅因为他们的外表、他们拥有的权力或金钱而享有特权。我感到内疚，因为我知道我并不比任何人优秀，所以我也应该和其他人一样接受同样的治疗。本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们探讨将奥利弗的原则（即所有的痛苦都应该同等看待）真正付诸实践意味着什么。
We speak with Australian philosopher Peter Singer who has tried to do this in his own life. What followed might surprise you. Some people have come to think of him as a monster. When we're asked to make a moral choice, most of us imagine it involves listening to our hearts. We all know right from wrong, and if we listen to the voice of conscience, it will guide us. My guest today says nonsense. The intuitions that produce moral judgment are unreliable and biased. It's far better, he says, to rely on logic, even mathematics. Peter Singer is a moral philosopher and professor of bioethics at Princeton University.
我们采访了澳大利亚哲学家彼得·辛格，他一直在自己的生活中践行这一点。接下来的内容可能会让你感到意外。有些人开始认为他是个怪物。当被要求做出道德选择时，我们大多数人都认为这涉及倾听我们的内心。我们都知道对与错，如果我们倾听良知的声音，它就会指引我们。我今天的嘉宾说，这纯属无稽之谈。产生道德判断的直觉是不可靠且带有偏见的。他说，依靠逻辑，甚至数学，要好得多。彼得·辛格是普林斯顿大学的道德哲学家和生物伦理学教授。
His ideas have attracted the kind of outsized admiration and passionate criticism not normally associated with philosophers. As the world grapples with an unprecedented moral dilemma, what to do in the face of the COVID-19 pandemic? We decided to take a deep dive into his ideas. Peter Singer, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, the pleasure to be with you. I understand that your parents were Jewish and fled Vienna for Australia in 1939. When you were a child growing up, did your parents tell you stories about what had happened? Did their experience fleeing
他的观点吸引了通常与哲学家无关的巨大赞赏和激烈的批评。正当世界在应对一场前所未有的道德困境——在COVID-19大流行面前该做些什么——时，我们决定深入探讨他的观点。彼得·辛格，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，很高兴能和你在一起。据我了解，你的父母是犹太人，于1939年从维也纳逃亡到澳大利亚。当你还是个孩子的时候，你的父母有没有给你讲过发生过的事情？他们逃亡的经历是否
Nazi Germany shaped the way that you talked about ethics or ethical issues around the dinner table? Certainly. We were very well aware of the fact that they had had to flee and that their parents, my grandparents, had not been able to escape with them. And although one of my four grandparents, my mother's mother, survived the war and came out to join us around the time that I was born in 1946, the others had perished in the Holocaust. Once I became a teenager and started reading history for myself,
纳粹德国的经历是否塑造了你在餐桌上谈论伦理或伦理问题的方式？当然。我们非常清楚他们不得不逃亡的事实，以及他们的父母——我的祖父母——未能与他们一起逃脱。虽然我的四个祖父母中的一个，我母亲的母亲，在战争中幸存下来，并在1946年我出生前后加入我们，但其他人在大屠杀中丧生了。当我成为一个少年并开始自己阅读历史时，
I developed a deeper understanding of the terrible events that my parents had been through and that their parents had died in. I remember friends who had tattoos on their arm because they'd been in concentration camps. This family history was the subtext as Peter grew up, left Australia, and went to Oxford for his studies. He gravitated to philosophy and a specific theory, utilitarianism. Many ideas in utilitarianism are revealed through difficult and painful moral dilemmas. A note to listeners that this next segment involves a discussion of the lynching of African-American men in the south. Utilitarianism is the view that the right thing to do is the one that has the best consequences and by best consequences does the most to increase the net surplus of happiness over misery. So in other words, increase the total amount of happiness to the greatest extent possible.
我对父母所经历的恐怖事件以及他们父母丧生的悲剧有了更深刻的理解。我记得有些朋友胳膊上有纹身，因为他们去过集中营。这种家族历史是彼得成长、离开澳大利亚并前往牛津求学的潜台词。他被哲学和一个特定的理论——功利主义——所吸引。功利主义中的许多观点是通过困难而痛苦的道德困境展现出来的。给听众的一则提示：接下来的部分将讨论对南方非裔美国人进行私刑处决的内容。功利主义的观点是，正确的事情是产生最好后果的那件事，而最好的后果意味着在最大程度上增加幸福相对于痛苦的净剩余。换句话说，就是在最大可能范围内增加幸福的总量。
So someone could listen to just what you just said and said that's entirely uncontroversial. Who would disagree with the idea that we should actually increase happiness to the next extent possible? What could possibly be the objections to this idea? Well, one objection is that it leads you to act contrary to generally accepted moral rules. So one of the examples that my electorate, James McCloskey, urged to show that in his view, you thought the tyrannism was wrong, imagined a situation in a southern town of the United States, going back into the
所以有人可能会听了你刚才说的话，然后说这完全是没有争议的。谁会不同意我们应该在最大程度上增加幸福感这个观点呢？对这个观点怎么可能会有反对意见呢？嗯，一个反对意见是，它会导致你的行为违背普遍接受的道德规则。因此，我的选区同事詹姆斯·麦克洛斯基为了表明在他看来你认为功利主义是错误的，举了这样一个例子：想象一下美国南部的一个小镇，回到
50s, let's say, when a white woman had been raped and said that she had been raped by an African American. And an angry mob of whites had grabbed half a dozen young African American men and was about to lynch them from a tree. And you're the sheriff of the town and you are powerless to stop this. You can't actually physically prevent them carrying out this lynching they've got guns too. If you tried, there would just be more bloodshed. So the only thing you can do to stop them lynching
20世纪50年代，假设一个白人女性被强奸了，并声称她是被一个非裔美国人强奸的。而一群愤怒的白人暴徒抓了半打年轻的非裔美国人，正准备把他们从树上吊死。而你是镇上的治安官，你却无力阻止这一切。你实际上无法物理阻止他们执行这场私刑，因为他们也有枪。如果你试图阻止，只会流更多的血。所以你能做的唯一一件事来阻止他们私刑处决
six people is to say, I've got proof that that's the one and point to one of the people that they've got. And then they will let go of the other five. But of course you don't have this proof. So you're lying and you're unjustly condemning one person to death. Now, Macloske thought that that would be the wrong thing for the sheriff to do, because the sheriff as an officer of the law should uphold justice and truth and not lie about evidence that he has. truth and not lie about evidence that he has. I didn't find that convincing if you really believe the situation that there's no other way to prevent six people dying. I thought that it was justified to do something that would let only one person die.
六个人的方法是说：“我有证据证明就是那个人”，并指出他们抓获的其中一个人。然后他们就会放过其他五个人。但当然你并没有这个证据。所以你在撒谎，你在不公正地判处一个人死刑。现在，麦克洛斯基认为治安官那样做是错误的，因为治安官作为法律的执行者，应该维护公正和真理，而不是对拥有的证据撒谎。真理而不是对他拥有的证据撒谎。我发现这并不令人信服，如果你真的相信除了这种方法之外没有其他办法阻止六个人死亡的话。我认为，做出某种只会让一个人死去的行为是正当的。
Sure that person is innocent but all of the six people are innocent too, presumably. people are innocent too presumably. So many people do think that that's would be wrong, that you must be truthful, that as an officer of the law cannot violate their promise to uphold the law faithfully and truthfully. And that's as one of many possible examples that people give against utilitarianism, that it will lead us in some circumstances to tell lies or even to kill an innocent person in order to save more or to violate individual rights in various ways. And some people think that these are moral absolutes, that you must never do something that would violate individual rights or tell a lie or kill an innocent person. And so when you sort of wrote the critique about what your professor's thesis was,
当然那个人是无辜的，但那六个人也都是无辜的，大概吧。人也是无辜的，大概吧。所以很多人确实认为那是错误的，你必须诚实，作为法律的执行者不能违背他们忠实且诚实地维护法律的承诺。这只是人们反对功利主义的众多可能例子之一，即它在某些情况下会导致我们说谎，甚至为了拯救更多人而杀死无辜的人，或者以各种方式侵犯个人权利。有些人认为这些是绝对道德，你绝不能做任何侵犯个人权利、说谎或杀死无辜之人的事情。所以当你写了关于你教授的论文的批判时，
your critique was basically, those absolutes in some way it's matter less than the absolute of saying, we should actually decrease the amount of suffering and increase the amount of happiness that whatever does that is in fact the morally correct thing to do. That's right. I reject it and still reject the idea that there are some things that are always wrong
你的批判基本上是：这些绝对准则在某种程度上不如“我们应该减少痛苦并增加幸福，任何能做到这一点的行为实际上才是道德上正确的行为”这一绝对准则重要。没错。我拒绝并且仍然拒绝那种认为有些事情无论后果如何都永远是错误的想法。
no matter what the consequences. I think that the consequences do determine what is right or wrong. And there are no moral absolutes where you must never do something in any imaginable circumstances. Many of us have heard the admonition, the ends do not justify the means. If doing something good requires us doing something bad in the process, you shouldn't do it. Peter has spent a lifetime asking a simple question. Why not? I do think that the unjustifies the means.
我认为后果确实决定了什么是对的还是错的。并没有那种在任何可以想象的情况下都绝对不能做的道德绝对准则。我们许多人都听过这样的告诫：目的不能使手段正当化。如果做一件好事的过程中需要我们做一件坏事，那就不应该去做。彼得用了一生时间在问一个简单的问题：为什么不呢？我确实认为目的能使手段正当化。
I think that's the point in a way that, of course, bad ends don't justify means. And if the means involve harming people people and there are other means that you could have taken, then you should take those other means. But if the only way to prevent something very bad happening is to do something which would itself be bad but not as bad as the very bad thing that you're trying to prevent happening, then you're justified in doing the lesser evil rather than allowing the greater evil to occur. So if killing one innocent person is the only way to save a larger number of innocent people from being killed, then I think that is the right thing to do.
我认为从某种意义上说，坏的目的当然不能使手段正当化。如果手段涉及伤害他人，并且还有你可以采取的其他手段，那么你应该采取那些其他手段。但如果阻止非常糟糕的事情发生的唯一方法，是去做一件本身很糟糕但并不如你试图阻止的那件极坏的事情那么糟糕的事，那么你选择较小的恶而不是允许较大的恶发生是正当的。因此，如果杀死一个无辜的人是拯救更多无辜的人免于被杀的唯一方法，那么我认为这是正确的事情。
So it's interesting when you sort of presented the thought experiment to me and I sort of put myself in the role of the sheriff. Clearly, of course, I can tell it certainly would be better to save the lives of five people than to not. I can clearly see that. But the idea of pointing at one person really makes me upset and it really makes me feel, this would be just terrible. Do you feel that? Peter, do you feel that this would be a terrible thing to do? Do you experience that emotionally in terms of how horrible the choice is? Oh, I do experience it emotionally, yes. It's the same idea incidentally that is in Dostoevsky's
所以这很有趣，当你向我提出那个思想实验，而我把自己代入治安官的角色时。很显然，我能看出拯救五个人的生命肯定比不救要好。我能清楚地看到这一点。但指出某一个特定的人的想法真的让我感到不安，它确实让我觉得，这太可怕了。你有这种感觉吗？彼得，你觉得这是一件可怕的事情吗？从选择有多糟糕的角度来看，你在情感上体验到这一点了吗？哦，我在情感上确实体验到了，是的。顺便说一句，这也是陀思妥耶夫斯基作品中的同一个观点
famous example in the brother's Karamazov, where he poses the question, suppose you could Caramazov where he poses the question, suppose you could create utopia forever, basically, peace on earth forever, but to do so you first have to torture this little child in front of your torture the child to death, I think he says, I don't remember exactly. Of course that's a horrendous idea, maybe I couldn't possibly torture a small child death, but if you ask me, would it be right to do that if you could? And if somehow that torturing this child really would mean that there was peace on Earth forever. And all of the millions of children who get killed and maimed and probably tortured too, in all of the wars that will otherwise occur for thousands of years into the future,
他在《卡拉马佐夫兄弟》中举了一个著名的例子，他在其中提出了这样一个问题：假设你可以卡拉马佐夫中他提出了这个问题，假设你可以永远创造乌托邦，基本上是永远的地球和平，但要做到这一点，你首先必须在你的面前折磨这个小孩子，把孩子折磨致死，我想他是这么说的，我记不清具体细节了。这当然是一个可怕的想法，也许我绝对不可能把一个小孩子折磨致死，但如果你问我，如果可以的话，这样做是对的吗？如果以某种方式折磨这个孩子真的意味着地球上永远和平。并且未来几千年里，在所有其他将会发生的战争中被杀害、残疾甚至可能遭受折磨的数百万儿童，
spared that horrible fate. Then I think torturing the child in front of you would be right, even though it would be incredibly repugnant. And as I say, maybe something that I just couldn't possibly bring myself to do. MUSIC Peter says in many circumstances, this feeling of repugnance can be useful. There are systems in the brain that automatically prompt us to what certain behaviors, or away from certain behaviors.
免于那种可怕的命运。那么我认为在面前折磨这个孩子是正确的，尽管这会让人极其反感。正如我所说，也许这只是我无论如何也无法让自己做到的事情。音乐彼得说，在许多情况下，这种反感的情感是有用的。大脑中存在一些系统，能够自动促使我们采取某些行为，或远离某些行为。
Much of the time, these intuitions are correct. But there are times when we need to override these impulses to account for the complexity of modern life. Doing this requires something that looks easy but is very hard. It requires you to ask what your principles are and then to act on them, regardless of the consequences, regardless of whether you feel like it. Peter has spent a lifetime overriding his intuitions. One of the earliest examples in his life came while he was studying at Oxford and went to have lunch with another student, Richard Keschen. We worked in the dining hall and there were two options for lunch.
大部分时间，这些直觉是正确的。但有时我们需要克服这些冲动，以应对现代生活的复杂性。做到这一点需要做一件看起来容易但实际上非常难的事。它要求你弄清楚自己的原则是什么，然后根据这些原则行事，不论后果如何，也不论你当时的感觉如何。彼得一生都在克制自己的直觉。他生活中的最早例子之一发生在他在牛津大学学习期间，当时他去和另一个学生理查德·凯申吃午饭。我们在餐厅工作，午餐有两种选择。
There was a hot dish which was a plate of spaghetti with some kind of brand sauce on the top of it. And there was a cold salad plate. So Richard asked the person serving, can you tell me whether there is meat in that sauce on the spaghetti? And the person said, yes, it's a meat sauce. So Richard then took the salad plate.
有一个热菜是一盘意大利面，上面浇着某种肉酱。还有一个冷沙拉盘。于是理查德问服务员：“你能告诉我那盘意大利面的酱里有没有肉吗？”服务员说：“是的，这是肉酱。”然后理查德拿了沙拉盘。
I took the spaghetti. It didn't think that the salad plate was going to satisfy my hunger. And we went off to eat together. And I was curious. So I asked Richard, I said, so what's your, why did you ask that question about the spaghetti source? Do you have a problem with meat?
我拿了意大利面。我不认为沙拉盘能满足我的饥饿感。我们一起去吃饭了。我很好奇。于是我问理查德，我说：“所以你的，你为什么要问关于意大利面酱的那个问题？你对肉有什么意见吗？”
And Richard said something that was really quite simple and that it took me by surprise. You know, I thought maybe it's, well, I'm an absolute pacifist and I think it's always wrong to kill any living being. Something of that sort, or perhaps he might have had some weird health views. Well, what I would have thought of weird at the time suggesting that meat wasn't good for you. But instead, he just said, I don't think it's right to treat animals the way we do treat them in order to turn them into meat. That surprised me because I thought that animals basically have good lives on farms, that they get to live a sort of natural life out in the fields. Then of course I knew that they get rounded up, they get trucked to the slaughterhouse and they get killed.
理查德说了一句非常简单的话，让我大吃一惊。你知道，我当时想也许它是，嗯，我是一个绝对的和平主义者，我认为杀死任何有生命的生物都是永远错误的。诸如此类的话，或者他可能有一些奇怪的健康观点。嗯，也就是我当时会认为是奇怪的观点，暗示肉对你不利。但相反，他只是说：“我认为以我们对待动物的方式来把它们变成肉是不对的。”这让我很吃惊，因为我以为动物在农场里基本上过着美好的生活，它们在田野里过着某种自然的生活。当然，我知道它们会被赶拢、用卡车运到屠宰场并被杀死。
But I suppose, you know, I hadn't thought about this issue very much at all, but my view would have been, well, they have good lives and then they have one really bad day. You know, that's not such a bad thing overall. But Richard said, no, that's not true. More and more animals are now indoors. They don't have good lives. They're very crowded and people do all sorts of things to them in order to produce their meat more cheaply. And I became aware of a whole lot of things about the way we treat animals that I really had no idea of, it just hadn't been an issue on my radar until then. But once I did become more aware of all of that, I just felt that I couldn't really justify it.
但我猜，你知道，我以前根本没怎么想过这个问题，我的观点会是，嗯，它们过着美好的生活，然后经历糟糕的一天。你知道，总体来说这并不是一件那么糟糕的事。但理查德说：“不，那不是真的。越来越多的动物现在呆在室内。它们没有美好的生活。它们非常拥挤，人们为了更便宜地生产肉类，对它们做了各种各样的事。”我开始了解到很多关于我们对待动物的方式的事情，而这些我以前完全不知道，直到那时这还不是一个进入我视线的问题。但一旦我真正对这一切有了更多了解，我只是觉得我真的无法为其辩护。
I talked to my wife about this. We'd got married just before it came to Oxford and she was ready to make that change, to stop eating meat and we became vegetarians. Within, I, say, about a month, sort of, of my mating routine. So there was another incident, maybe around the same time. There also, I think, reveals how you sort of are taking these ideas and sort of acting on them in ways that other people say, yeah, I sort of agree with the ideas, but it doesn't necessarily change my behavior. There was news breaking out of South Asia from the country of what is now
我和我妻子谈过这件事。我们刚来牛津之前就结婚了，她已经准备好做出改变，停止吃肉，我们成了素食主义者。我想，在我交往后的一个月左右吧。所以还有另一次事件，大约也在同一时期。这也反映了你是如何接受这些想法并以其他人会说“我某种程度上同意这些想法，但它不一定改变我的行为”的方式来付诸行动的。南亚地区当时正爆发新闻，来自现在的那个国家
Bangladesh. Can you describe to me what it is you heard and what it prompted you to do? Well, when I was a student in Oxford, Pakistan essentially had two geographically separate parts on different sides of India. There's what is now Pakistan was then West Pakistan and there was a separate part of the country called East Pakistan. And there was a movement in East Pakistan for more autonomy for to not be ruled by West Pakistan which dominated the nation as a whole. So I was reading in the news about this autonomy movement
孟加拉国。你能向我描述一下你听到了什么以及它促使你做了什么吗？嗯，当我在牛津做学生时，巴基斯坦基本上在印度的不同两侧有两个地理上分离的部分。现在是巴基斯坦的那部分当时被称为西巴基斯坦，还有一个被称为东巴基斯坦的国家独立部分。东巴基斯坦出现了一场运动，要求获得更多自治权，不再受作为一个整体统治国家的西巴基斯坦的统治。所以我当时在新闻里读到这场自治运动
and it seemed like a democratic movement that's kind of thing that I would support. But it was brutally repressed by the Pakistani army. Refugees started fleeing across the border from what was Danny's Pakistan into India. So essentially into the Indian part of Bengal. Nine million in total, fled across the border, so a very large flow of refugees into what was then a very poor country, India was much poorer than it is today, and India simply said
这似乎是一场民主运动，正是我会支持的那种运动。但它遭到巴基斯坦军队的残酷镇压。难民开始跨越边境，从当时的东巴基斯坦逃往印度。基本上就是逃到印度的孟加拉国地区。总共有九00万人越过边境，因此有非常大量的难民涌入当时的贫穷国家印度（当时的印度比今天要穷得多），而印度简单地表示
you know they cannot cope with nine million refugees, the cost of providing shelter, sanitation and food and so on was overwhelming for that country and they appealed to help to the affluent countries. And some organizations in England where I was living in Picular Oxfam, I started appealing for funds to assist the refugees. And that led me to start thinking about one of my obligations. Here, I'm living in Oxford. I'm certainly not rich. I was on a graduate student scholarship, and my wife was a high school teacher. But we have more than we need. We're planning a holiday in Europe over the summer, on the coast of the continent. And so should we be doing something about this?
你知道，他们无力应对九00万难民，提供住所、环境卫生和食物等成本对那个国家来说是难以承受的，他们呼吁富裕国家伸出援手。我当时居住的英国的一些组织，特别是乐施会（Oxfam），开始呼吁资金来援助难民。这促使我开始思考我的一项义务。当时我住在牛津。我绝对不富裕。我靠着研究生奖学金生活，我的妻子是一名高中老师。但我们拥有的比我们需要的多。我们正计划夏天去欧洲度假，去欧洲大陆海岸。那么我们应该为此做点什么吗？
And that led me to start thinking, yes, it's not enough to just throw a few coins in a tin when it's rattled under your nose, that we ought to be making a more substantial commitment. And my wife and I started giving 10% of what we earned to Oxfam, both for the crisis in East Pakistan, which was eventually resolved by the Indian Army, invading East Pakistan and allowing the autonomy movement to declare the independent state of Bangladesh, which of course exists today.
这促使我开始思考，是的，当别人把零钱盒在你鼻子底下摇晃时，仅仅扔进去几个硬币是不够的，我们应该做出更实质性的承诺。我和妻子开始将我们收入的10%捐给乐施会，既为了东巴基斯坦的危机——该危机最终通过印度军队入侵东巴基斯坦并允许自治运动宣布成立孟加拉国独立国家而得到解决，孟加拉国当然今天依然存在。
But I was aware that even though that temporary crisis had been resolved, that there were millions of people in the world in great need who were dying or his children were dying because of extreme poverty that we, more affluent people people could help to alleviate and could help to change the situation for significant numbers of people. Are you still donating 10% of your income? I'm not donating 10% of my income now because I've got a lot more income than I had when I was a graduate student and I can afford to donate significantly more than 10%. So now I'm donating at least a third of my income each year. Sometimes it's
但我意识到，尽管那场临时的危机已经得到解决，世界上仍有数百万处于极度贫困中的人们在死去，或者他们的孩子在死去，而我们这些更富裕的人本可以帮助缓解并改变大量人群的现状。你现在还在捐出收入的10%吗？我现在没有捐出收入的10%，因为我的收入比当研究生时多得多，我有能力捐出比10%显著更多的钱。所以现在我每年至少捐出收入的三分之一。有时会
been closer to half, but it's in that sort of region between a third and a half. I'm wondering whether you yourself still experience any struggles with your own impulses. Do you feel excuses, as you call them, bubble up inside you to say, I really wish there was a loophole around my principles? Well, I do struggle, but for me, the struggle is that I don't think that giving a third or even half of my income really would be enough. I think that I'd be a better person if I were to give, let's say, two thirds or 80% and live more cheaply than I do. I'm still living a very comfortable life. So, yes, there's always a struggle. Unless you're a complete saint and you've given
更接近一半，但大概在三分之一到一半之间。我想知道你自己是否仍然会经历与自己的冲动作斗争的情况？你是否觉得正如你所说的借口在你内心涌现，对你说，我真的希望在我的原则周围有一个漏洞？嗯，我的确在挣扎，但对我来说，挣扎在于我不认为捐出我收入的三分之一甚至一半真的就足够了。我认为如果我捐出比如说三分之二或者百分之八十，并且过得比现在更简朴，我会成为一个更好的人。我仍然过着非常舒适的生活。所以，是的，总会有挣扎。除非你是一个完全的圣人并且你已经捐出了
away everything except what you need to live and perhaps to be an effective campaigner for change. Until you get to that point, I think you should be struggling. I acknowledge I'm not a saint, so there is a struggle going on. This struggle between our values and our actions is one that has ramifications across many dimensions of our lives. That's especially true as individuals and nations respond to the COVID-19 pandemic. More when we come back. Philosopher Peter Singer has built his life around a radical idea. Logic and calculation are better guides to moral behavior than feelings and intuitions.
除了你生活所需以及可能成为变革的有效活动家所需之外的一切。在你达到那个点之前，我认为你应该在挣扎。我承认我不是一个圣人，所以确实存在着挣扎。这种在我们的价值观和我们的行动之间的挣扎，在我们的生活中的许多维度都有着深远的影响。当个人和国家对2019冠状病毒病疫情做出回应时，情况尤其如此。稍后回来。哲学家彼得·辛格围绕一个激进的理念建立了他的人生。逻辑和计算比情感和直觉更能指引道德行为。
Reason dictates that your suffering doesn't count for more than someone else's suffering. If you believe that all lives are equal, and most people say they do, you should make choices that limit the greatest amount of suffering, regardless of whether that suffering is your own, or that of an animal in a factory farm, or that of a stranger halfway around the planet. Lots of people can think of a simple way to follow these principles.
理性表明，你的痛苦并不比别人的痛苦更重要。如果你相信所有生命都是平等的（大多数人都这么说），你就应该做出能够将最大程度的痛苦降到最低的选择，而不管这种痛苦是你自己的、工厂化农场里动物的痛苦，还是地球另一端陌生人的痛苦。许多人可以想到一种遵循这些原则的简单方法。
If you believe all lives are equal and all suffering counts the same. Do your best to avoid causing harm to others. Don't hurt people, don't cause suffering. But most of us don't think of the suffering that we don't cause as our responsibility. Peter Singer says, A-A. Acts of omission matter just as much as acts of commission. If you're the sheriff faced with the moral dilemma of killing one innocent to save the lives of five innocent people, and you wash your hands of the problem because it's not of your
如果你相信所有生命都平等且所有痛苦都同等重要。尽你最大努力避免对他人造成伤害。不要伤害人，不要造成痛苦。但我们大多数人不把我们没有造成的痛苦视为我们的责任。彼得·辛格说，不作为的行为与作为的行为同样重要。如果你是治安官，面对杀死一个无辜者来拯救五个无辜者生命的道德困境，而你洗手不管这个问题，因为这不是你
causing, then yes, you too have blood on your hands. The idea that we're responsible for our omissions as well as our acts is one that struck me most in terms of life and death decisions in medicine and in health care. One of the issues that I came across this time when I was a graduate student in thinking about ethical issues, was the practice of allowing severely disabled infants
造成的，那么是的，你的手上同样沾满了鲜血。我们不仅对自己的行为负责，也对自己的不作为负责的观点，在医学和医疗保健中的生死决策方面给我留下了深刻的印象。当我还是个研究生、思考伦理问题时遇到的问题之一，就是允许严重残疾的婴儿
to die, but refusing to take active steps to end their lives. Among the case studies that Peter looked at were infants born with spinal bifida. This is a condition in which the spine and spinal cord don't develop properly, sometimes leading to problems that can range from cognitive impairment to paralysis. Now, I learned that there was a doctor in Sheffield called John Lorba, and Sheffield happened to be a kind of hot spot for spine of iftar for reasons that went clearly understood but so he got a lot of these cases and he'd observed them for for many years and he decided that sometimes
死亡，但拒绝采取积极措施结束他们的生命的做法。彼得研究的案例之一是天生患有脊柱裂的婴儿。这是一种脊椎和脊髓发育不正常的疾病，有时会导致从认知障碍到瘫痪等各种问题。现在，我了解到谢菲尔德有一位名叫约翰·洛巴（John Lorba）的医生，而谢菲尔德恰好是脊柱裂的一个高发地，原因并不完全清楚，但他接诊了许多这类病例，并且观察了他们多年，他决定有时
he was saving babies for lives that were miserable for them and very difficult to cope with for their parents or other Children that their parents might have. So he decided that sometimes in the more severe cases it was better not to operate, not to try to save the child's life. But he then described the fate of the children, that they died slowly. Dr. Lobba would not treat an infection if they got for example, so they would get an infection, they would get feverish and they might die from the infection because he thought that was better than surviving. Or maybe they would not feed them, and essentially they would starve, perhaps they would be doped up so they
他在拯救那些对他们来说痛苦不堪、对他们的父母或其他孩子或父母可能有的其他孩子来说很难应付的婴儿。所以他决定有时在更严重的病例中，最好不要做手术，不要试图拯救孩子的生命。但他接着描述了这些孩子的命运，他们慢慢地死去。洛巴医生不会治疗他们感染的疾病（如果他们感染了的话），所以他们会感染，会发烧，并可能死于感染，因为他认为这比存活下来要好。或者也许他们不会喂养他们，本质上他们会挨饿，也许他们会被注射药物以免
went suffering, but they would die of lack of food or water. And I thought this is crazy. Here's a doctor who's decided that it's better that these babies should die, but he's letting them with the parents agreement, I suppose, but he's letting them die slow, lingering, painful deaths that are bad for the babies, a terrible strain on the parents, and also on the hospital staff, the nursing staff in particular, you know, was against all their instincts to not treat a treatable infection in a small child. So I thought, well, if you're going to make that decision, why not end the child's life? Why not give the child the lethal injection?
他们遭受痛苦，但他们会因缺乏食物或水而死。我觉得这太疯狂了。这里有一位医生，他决定这些婴儿死掉更好，但他在父母的同意下（我想是的）让它们慢慢地、拖延地、痛苦地死去，这对婴儿不好，对父母是可怕的折磨，对医院工作人员（尤其是护士）也是如此，你知道，不治疗小孩子可以治疗的感染违背了他们所有的直觉。所以我想，嗯，如果你要做那个决定，为什么不结束孩子的生命呢？为什么不给孩子注射致死剂量的药物呢？
Now, that was illegal and I guess Lohba couldn't do it for that reason even if he thought it was best. But I looked at the medical literature and a lot of doctors seem to think that that would have been wrong, that what Lohba was doing was okay. So, you know, that's the clear example where I thought you're responsible for what you're doing in these circumstances. You're responsible for ending the child's life. Why do it in a way that causes more suffering than another way that would have the same result that is actually the result that you're trying to seek, the death of the child?
现在，那是违法的，我想洛巴即使认为那是最好的，也无法因此而那样做。但我查阅了医学文献，许多医生似乎认为那样做是错的，洛巴正在做的事情是可以接受的。所以，你知道，这是一个清晰的例子，我认为你在这些情况下要对你所做的事情负责。你要对结束孩子的生命负责。为什么要以一种比另一种会产生相同结果（即你实际试图寻求的结果——孩子的死亡）的方式造成更多痛苦的方式来做呢？
The combination of these two basic principles, act of omission, matter as much as act of commission, and all suffering counts equally, let Peter to develop a thought experiment that has now become famous. I asked my readers to imagine that they are walking across a park that has a pond in it and an ornamental pond and when they walk past the pond, they see that a small child seems to have fallen into pond and is evidently in danger of drowning. The first thing that they do is to look around and say, who's looking after this child? There must be somebody, it must be a parent or a babysitter who's looking after the child,
这两种基本原则的结合——不作为的行为与作为的行为同样重要，以及所有的痛苦同等重要——促使彼得提出了一个如今已变得著名的思想实验。我要求我的读者想象他们正走过一个公园，公园里有一个池塘、一个观赏池塘，当他们走过池塘时，他们看到一个小孩似乎掉进了池塘里，并且显然处于溺水的危险之中。他们要做的第一件事就是四处张望，然后说：“谁在照顾这个孩子？一定有人在，一定是一个父母或保姆在照顾这个孩子，”
but on looking around they don't see anybody. They doesn't seem to be anybody in the park except them and a small child. So the next thought is I'd better help this child, I'd better jump into the pond and save the child and they know that there's no risk to them in doing so. But there is a cost because they're going somewhere special, they've put on their best clothing, very expensive pair of shoes that they're wearing, I don't really have time to get rid of them if they're going to save the child. So then they're struck with the thought that, well, would it really be wrong if I just ignored this child? I don't want to ruin my nice shoes, I don't want to get all cold and wet from the pond.
但环顾四周，他们没有看到任何人。除了他们和一个小孩之外，公园里似乎没有别人。所以接下来的想法是：我最好去帮帮这个孩子，我最好跳进池塘把孩子救上来，并且他们知道这样做对自己没有任何风险。但这样做是有代价的，因为他们要去某个特殊的地方，他们穿上了最好的衣服，脚上穿着非常昂贵的鞋子，如果要救孩子，他们真的没有时间把鞋子脱掉。所以他们脑海中闪过这样一个想法：“嗯，如果我只是忽视这个孩子，真的会错吗？我不想毁了我漂亮的鞋子，我不想让池塘的水弄得又冷又湿。”
It's not my child, it's not my responsibility. Nobody asked me to look after this child. So why don't I just go on my way? And at that point I ask you the listener or the reader to think about whether that would be the right thing to do or an acceptable thing to do or whether it would be wrong. the right thing to do or an acceptable thing to do, or whether it would be wrong. And of course, most people would say it's unthinkable to walk by and let the child run. Exactly. Most people say that would be terrible. That would be an awful thing to do.
“这不是我的孩子，这不是我的责任。没有人要求我照顾这个孩子。那我为什么不直接走我的路呢？”在那个时候，我请你——听者或读者——去思考这是否是一件正确的事、一件可以接受的事，或者它是否是错误的。一件正确的事、一件可以接受的事，或者它是否是错误的。当然，大多数人会说，从旁边走过并让孩子淹死是不可想象的。没错。大多数人会说那太可怕了。那将是一件极其糟糕的事。
What kind of a person could put a pair of shoes no matter how expensive above the life of a small child. So that's the reaction that I'm hoping people will have, and as you say, overwhelmingly they do have that reaction. But then I point out that even though no doubt they would jump into the pond and save the child, they are saying that we are under an obligation to help or it would be awful not to help, people whose lies we could say are small costs to ourselves. So if that's the case, then how are we situated with regard to people in extreme poverty,
什么样的人会把一双鞋子（无论多贵）看得比一个小孩子的生命还重要呢？所以这就是我希望人们会有的反应，正如你所说，绝大多数人确实有那种反应。但接着我指出，尽管毫无疑问他们会跳进池塘救出孩子，但他们是在说，我们有义务去帮助那些如果我们付出微小的代价就能拯救其生命的人，或者不这样做将是可怕的。既然如此，那么我们与极度贫困人群的关系又是怎样的呢？
given that there are people who are dying for, let's say, the lack of a bed net to protect themselves or their children from malaria. And bed nets are very cheap. You know, you don't save a child's life with every bed net, but if you give enough to the against malaria foundation, you can be pretty confident that you will have saved a child's life. So if it would be awful not to save the child in front of you, isn't it also awful not to do anything to save children who you know are dying, who are not in front of you, who
鉴于有些人正在死去，比如说，因为缺少一顶蚊帐来保护自己或他们的孩子免受疟疾侵害。而蚊帐非常便宜。你知道，你并不是用每一顶蚊帐都能救一个孩子的人命，但如果你向抗击疟疾基金会（Against Malaria Foundation）捐赠足够多的钱，你就可以相当自信地认为你已经拯救了一个孩子的生命。所以，如果不去拯救眼前的孩子是可怕的，那么不去采取任何行动去拯救那些你知道正在死去、却不在你眼前、
are far away from you, you can't see them or even identify as individuals the children whose lives you're saving. But you can be highly confident that you are saving the lives of some children. And isn't it wrong just to go on with our lives spending money on things we don't need when that money could be saving lives? And that's the core argument that I've been making over many years now for saying that if we really want to live an ethical life, it's not enough just to observe those moral rules and say, don't do this, don't do that. We really also need, in the world in which we're living, to do something significant,
离你很远、你看不到、甚至无法作为个体来识别你所拯救其生命的儿童，难道不是同样可怕的吗？但你可以高度确信，你确实在拯救某些孩子的生命。难道把钱花在我们不需要的东西上、而这些钱本可以拯救生命，就这样继续我们的生活，不是错误的吗？这就是我多年来一直在阐述的核心论点，即如果我们真的想过一种有道德的生活，仅仅遵守那些道德规则并说“不要做这个，不要做那个”是不够的。在这个我们生活的世界里，我们确实还需要做出重大的行动，
to help people who, through no fault of their own, are in great need and who are in danger of dying, or whose children are in danger of dying because of things that we could provide for them. What would happen if we took these ideas and applied them to the COVID-19 pandemic? For a start, it should prompt many of us who can to reach for a checkbook and send money to groups that are working to relieve suffering around the world. That's the easy part. But there are much more difficult implications.
去帮助那些并非由于自身过错而处于极大困苦中、正面临死亡危险的人，或者由于我们可以提供的东西而面临孩子夭折危险的人。如果我们把这些想法应用到COVID-19大流行中会发生什么？首先，它应该促使我们当中许多有能力的人掏出支票簿，向那些致力于缓解全球痛苦的群体汇款。这是容易的部分。但还有更困难的影响。
Let's go back a second to that thought experiment involving the sheriff and the six innocent men who are about to be killed. If you're a utilitarian, you think it's better to cause the death of one innocent, if that means you can save five others. But it doesn't stop there. You can also ask, which of the six should I kill? From a utilitarian perspective, you would take into account how all the men are, whether they have underlying illnesses. If one of them is more likely to die sooner than the others, ending his life imposes the smallest costs.
让我们回过头去看一下那个涉及治安官和六个即将被处决的无辜男人的思想实验。如果你是一个功利主义者，你认为如果这意味着你能拯救另外五个人，那么导致一个无辜者的死亡会更好。但不仅于此。你还可以问：这六个人中我应该杀哪一个？从功利主义的角度来看，你会考虑所有这些男人的年龄，他们是否有基础疾病。如果其中一个人比其他人更有可能更早去世，那么结束他的生命所带来的代价是最小的。
It's the least evil. In the context of a pandemic, Peter asked me to think about how this logic might apply to questions of triage. When a hospital has more people who need to be on a ventilator than they have ventilators and so they have to make decisions and traditionally decisions. And traditionally, medical ethics has taken the view that if somebody is on event later and someone else needs event later, the person who is on the event later has priority, it's kind of first come first served. But in the pandemic, I think that has shifted a bit. And particularly because there are many older people affected by the pandemic. So people in Italy, for example,
这是最小的恶。在大流行的背景下，彼得让我思考这种逻辑如何应用于分诊问题。当一家医院需要呼吸机的人数超过了他们拥有的呼吸机数量时，他们必须做出决策，而传统上，决策。传统上，医学伦理学的观点是，如果某人正在使用呼吸机，而另一个人也需要呼吸机，正在使用呼吸机的人拥有优先权，这有点像先到先得。但在大流行期间，我认为情况发生了一些变化。特别是因为有许多老年人受大流行影响。因此，比如意大利的人们，
considered the question. So suppose that the person on the ventilator is 85 years old and will need the ventilator for quite a long time, whereas you have a young person who's having acute respiratory distress, but probably will only need the ventilator for a short time. And in any case, once they get over this, we'll have the prospect of maybe another 40 years of life, where obviously
考虑了这个问题。所以假设使用呼吸机的人已经85岁了，将需要呼吸机相当长的一段时间，而你有一个年轻人，他正在经历急性呼吸窘迫，但可能只需要很短时间的呼吸机。而且无论如何，一旦他们挺过这一关，将有望再活大约40年，而很显然
the person who is 85 can't expect anything near that in terms of life expectancy. So, doctors in Italy developed codes which suggested that it's okay to remove people from ventilators in order to put other people with better chances of survival and greater life expectancy onto the ventilators. Clearly, you're choosing some lives over others, it's a matter of years of life that you're saving rather than lives that you're saving. But possibly you may be saving more lives too because if one person is going to need a ventilator for a month and there are 10 other people who would need it only for three days, then you'll save more lives as well if you save it for the people who have a short term need for it. Now if you're 85, this kind of logic could make you very angry.
85岁的人在预期寿命方面根本无法与此相比。因此，意大利的医生制定了一些准则，建议将病人从呼吸机上撤下是允许的，以便将那些生存机会更好、预期寿命更长的其他人放到呼吸机上。很显然，你在一些生命中做出选择，这是关于你正在拯救的生命年数，而不是你正在拯救的生命数量的问题。但可能你也在拯救更多的生命，因为如果一个人需要一个月的呼吸机，而其他10个人只需要三天，那么如果你把它留给那些短期需要它的人，你也将拯救更多的生命。现在，如果你已经85岁了，这种逻辑可能会让你非常愤怒。
As I said, few philosophers have drawn the kind of admiration and the kind of anger that Peter has attracted. But Peter wants you to remember something through that anger. The doctor who decides not to intervene and who gets the ventilator, just like the sheriff in the moral dilemma, is making life in death choices. Why not make them rationally, deliberately, honestly? How is it morally superior to allow a greater amount of suffering just because one person showed up in the emergency room 10 minutes before another person? Is the first calm, first served rule
正如我所说，很少有哲学家能像彼得那样激起如此巨大的赞赏和愤怒。但彼得希望你在那种愤怒中记住一件事。那个决定不干预并获得呼吸机的医生，就像道德困境中的治安官一样，正在做出生死抉择。为什么不理性地、刻意地、诚实地做出这些选择呢？仅仅因为一个人比另一个人早10分钟出现在急诊室，就允许更大数量的痛苦发生，这怎么就在道德上更优越了呢？先到先得的规则难道不是
designed to minimize harm or is it designed to keep doctors from having to make painful choices, to keep doctors from feeling like that sheriff. Peter says utilitarianism has something important to say about the responses of many governments to the COVID-19 pandemic. In a recent essay that he co-wrote with another researcher, he said, it pains us to say this, but US President Donald Trump is right. We cannot let the cure be worse than the disease. I asked him to explain what he meant.
旨在将伤害降至最低，还是为了让医生免于做出痛苦的选择，让医生免于像那位治安官那样感受痛苦？彼得说，功利主义对于许多政府应对新冠肺炎大流行的反应，有重要的话语要说。在最近的一篇他与另一位研究人员合写的文章中，他说，说出这话让我们感到痛苦，但美国总统唐纳德·特朗普是对的。我们不能让治愈的代价比疾病本身更糟。我请他解释一下他的意思。
Well, Trump was suggesting that possibly the lockdown might actually have worse consequences than the virus itself would have if it spread through the community. Now what we were saying is that that's a reasonable question to ask. If there is evidence that the costs of the lockdown are worse than the costs of leaving the virus to spread throughout the community, then we should not of the lockdown are worse than the costs of leaving the virus to spread throughout the community, then we should not have the lockdown. We were not saying, and we tried to take pains to make clear that we were not competent to say, that that was the case, or that the costs of the lockdown are worse than having the virus.
嗯，特朗普的暗示是，封锁实际上可能比病毒本身在社区传播时造成的后果更糟糕。现在我们要说的是，这是一个合理的问题。如果有证据表明封锁的代价比任由病毒在社区传播的代价更高，那么我们就不应该进行封锁。我们并不是说——我们也极力澄清——我们有资格断定事实确实如此，或者封锁的代价比感染病毒更糟。
That's something for the medical experts and the other social scientists who can tell us what the cost of the lockdown are, a very big and complicated question, and of course the hypothetical question of what would happen if the virus spread unchecked through the community. But we do think that that's the right question to ask. You know, we have to try to think, what are we doing with this lockdown? How bad is it and how bad is the alternative? That's the only rational basis on which you could make policy decisions about whether to go into lockdown and once you're in lockdown, when to start lifting the restrictions.
这是医学专家和其他社会科学家需要探讨的问题，他们能告诉我们封锁的代价是什么，这是一个非常庞大且复杂的问题，当然还有一个假设性问题，即如果病毒在社区中不受控制地传播会发生什么。但我们确实认为这是一个正确的问题。你知道，我们必须试着思考，我们通过封锁在做什么？它有多糟糕，替代方案又有多糟糕？这是你据以做出政策决定——是否进入封锁状态，以及一旦进入封锁状态何时开始解除限制——的唯一理性基础。
So I want to make clear that there are, it's a very complicated issue and there are lots of nuances here. The question is, even if you lift the lock down, maybe people actually won't come back and engage in economic activity until they're actually confident about their public health. There's lots of nuances in terms of, you know, how much of a choice governments are actually making and so forth, but separate from the specific policy
所以我想澄清的是，这是一个非常复杂的问题，其中有很多细微差别。问题在于，即使你解除了封锁，人们实际上可能也不会回来参与经济活动，直到他们对公共卫生真正充满信心。在政府实际上做出了多少选择等方面有很多细微差别，但抛开具体的政策
prescriptions, just to stay with the domain of the moral choices that we're making. I want you to try and articulate for me how it is that this can actually have moral consequences because the downstream effects of some of the choices we are making can affect people down the road in ways that are unpredictable. You describe, for example, at one point in this essay that one way to make progress is to consider that a lockdown, if it goes on long enough, will bring about a smaller economy that can afford fewer doctors, nurses, and medicines.
规定不谈，仅就我们正在做出的道德选择领域而言。我希望你试着为我阐述，这实际上是如何产生道德后果的，因为我们做出的一些选择的下游效应可能会以不可预测的方式影响未来的人们。例如，你在文章的某处写到，取得进展的一种途径是考虑到，如果封锁持续足够长的时间，将会带来一个规模更小的经济体，从而负担得起更少医生、护士和药物。
You say in the United Kingdom, the National Health Service estimates that for about $30,000 can buy a patient an extra year of healthy life, basically making the argument that a smaller economy can have health consequences. Particularly this for me a little bit more, and again I think less in terms of the Pacific prescriptions in terms of COVID-19, as much as exploring sort of what the moral terrain is on which these discussions are based. The ultimate moral question here is what are our values and what is it that we are trying to promote. Now clearly it's a bad thing when people who want to go on living die and that's a bad thing even if they're quite elderly and would only have one or two years to live, it's still a bad thing. But we need to balance that against a broader range of consequences that can occur from
你说在英国，国家医疗服务体系估计大约3万英镑可以为一个患者买到一年额外的健康生命，这基本上是在论证较小的经济体可能会带来健康后果。特别是这一点对我来说更深入了一些，再次说明，我认为这较少从针对新冠肺炎的具体规定来考虑，而是更多地探讨这些讨论所基于的道德土壤。这里的终极道德问题是我们的价值观是什么，我们试图弘扬的是什么。显然，想要继续活下去的人死去是一件坏事，即使他们年事已高，只剩一两年可活，这也是一件坏事。但我们需要在这一点与由此产生的更广泛的后果之间进行权衡
an economic recession. And those consequences are very many. One of them is widespread unemployment. We've seen more than 30 million Americans registering for unemployment in the past month or so. So that has its cost, perhaps people are going hungry or unable to do other essential, meet other essential needs. There have been reports of higher incidences of domestic violence because people are locked up
一场经济衰退。这些后果非常之多。其中之一就是广泛的失业。我们在过去一个月左右的时间里看到超过3000万美国人进行了失业登记。所以这有它的代价，也许人们正在挨饿，或者无法做其他基本的事情，满足其他基本需求。有报道称，由于人们被关在
at home together and feeling frustrated and angry at not being able to get out of the home. And in the long term, the effects of a smaller economy that governments have less money to spend and that can have an effect on saving lives. It can have an effect on how many healthcare workers can be educated and trained, what kinds of facilities they can have, how good the healthcare system might be. So we need to have some kind of common unit to weigh up these quite diverse costs of the lockdown against the more specific and identifiable costs of how many extra people will die.
家中彼此相处，感到沮丧和愤怒，无法出门，导致家庭暴力事件发生率上升。从长远来看，经济规模缩小的影响是政府用于开支的资金减少，这可能会对拯救生命产生影响。它会影响可以培养和培训多少医护人员，他们可以拥有什么样的设施，医疗保健系统会有多好。因此，我们需要某种共同的单位来权衡这些截然不同的封锁成本，与究竟会有多少额外人口死亡这一更具体、更可辨别的成本。
And I would say not just a number of people who will die, but the number of life years that will be lost. Because I do think that it's worse for somebody who's 30 to die than it is for somebody who's 85. So in the article we suggest that we should be trying to look at years of positive life, years of life with certain levels of satisfaction and trying to compare the loss of what economists call quality adjusted life years in the two situations. So, quality adjusted life years will be lost in whether you are talking about deaths from the virus or whether you're talking about the reduction in quality that comes through the lockdown.
而且我要说的是，不仅会死多少人，还将失去多少生命年。因为我确实认为30岁的人死亡比85岁的人死亡更糟糕。因此，我们在文章中建议，我们应该着眼于积极生命的年数、具有一定满意度水平的生命年数，并试图比较经济学家所说的两处情境下的质量调整生命年的损失。因此，无论你谈论的是病毒造成的死亡，还是谈论的是封锁带来的生活质量下降，质量调整生命年都会损失。
You're talking the essay about something you call an identified victim effect and an identified cause effect. In the second case, you sort of say, could the images of people dying on stretchers and tents in hospital parking lots be blinding us to the greater harm we may be causing across society through our efforts to avoid those awful deaths? What are these two ideas, the identified victim effect and the identified cause effect? The identified victim effect is something that is well known and has been widely studied. And that is that we are much more reluctant to harm a person who is identified or not
你在文章中谈到了一个你称之为“已识别受害者效应”和“已识别原因效应”的概念。在第二种情况下，你有点像在说，医院停车场里人们躺在担架和帐篷里死去的画面，会不会让我们对通过避免这些可怕死亡的努力而对整个社会造成的更大伤害视而不见？这两个概念——已识别受害者效应和已识别原因效应——是什么？已识别受害者效应是一个众所周知且被广泛研究的现象。也就是说，我们更加不愿意伤害一个被识别的人，或者说不愿意
to help a person who is identified than a stranger. And this I think is operating in my example of the drowning child in a pond. You can see the child in front of you. So you have an identified victim and people think it would be terrible not to say that child, and emotionally there is a very strong pull to save the child in front of you. Whereas when people say to you, you could save a child by donating to the Against Malaria Foundation. There is no identified victim, it's just an anonymous child. And in the nature
去帮助一个被识别的人，而不是一个陌生人。我认为这在我的池塘溺水儿童的例子中发挥了作用。你可以看到眼前的这个孩子。因此，你有一个被识别的受害者，人们认为不救那个孩子将是可怕的，从情感上讲，拯救眼前的孩子有着非常强大的吸引力。而当人们对你说，你可以通过向反疟疾基金会捐款来拯救一个孩子时。没有被识别的受害者，这只是一个匿名的孩子。而且从本质上讲
of the bed nets, you'll never be able to identify the victim, in fact, because you don't know which of them would have gotten bitten by a mosquito and died if you hadn't provided the bed nets. So people don't feel the same emotional pull to donate to what we sometimes call statistical victims. We know that statistically, bed nets save lives, but we can't say this is the child that you've saved. So that's what operates familiar phenomenon that operates in terms of who people are willing to donate to rescue. Now, in the case of the choice between
蚊帐的本质是，你永远无法识别受害者，事实上，因为如果你不提供蚊帐，你根本不知道他们当中谁会被蚊子叮咬而死。因此，人们对我们有时所说的统计学受害者捐款并没有那种强烈的情感吸引力。我们知道，从统计学上讲，蚊帐可以挽救生命，但我们不能说这就是你拯救的孩子。所以这就是人们愿意向谁捐款救援这一熟悉现象背后的运作机制。现在，在选择
allowing the virus to spread and the lockdown what we have is not identifiable victims because we don't know in advance who the virus will kill but we have an identifiable cause the virus so we can count the number of deaths caused by the virus there's some borderline inaccuracy in doing that but we can get a rough idea of that. And we can say, oh, this is terrible if the government had locked things down, these people wouldn't have had to die.
允许病毒传播还是封锁，我们面对的不是可识别的受害者，因为我们无法提前知道病毒会杀死谁，但我们有一个可识别的起因——病毒，所以我们可以计算出病毒造成的死亡人数，虽然在这样做时存在一些边界上的不准确性，但我们可以对此有一个粗略的了解。我们可以说，哦，这太可怕了，如果政府封锁了，这些人本不必死。
The virus would not have spread. But when people are dying because of the broader effects of the economic recession, because of the fact that the government has not got so many resources to train health professionals or even to make roads safer or to do a whole range of other things that save lives. We don't know. We don't really know whether that was caused by the recession or whether it had some other causes. So I think we are So, I think we are biased to give more weight to the identifiable cause rather than the causes that are much more disparate and difficult to identify, but which we can still estimate will cause losses of life.
病毒就不会传播了。但是当人们因为经济衰退的更广泛影响而死亡，因为政府没有那么多资源来培训卫生专业人员，甚至无法让道路变得更安全，或者无法做一系列其他拯救生命的事情时。我们不知道。我们真的不知道那是经济衰退引起的，还是有其他原因。所以我想我们是……所以，我认为我们倾向于给可识别的原因赋予更多权重，而不是那些更加零散且难以识别，但我们仍然可以估计会导致生命损失的原因。
And that perhaps tends to push us in the direction of favoring the lockdown to avoid the deaths from the identifiable cause, the virus, rather than to give full weight to the deaths that are going to be caused and the loss of quality of life that are going to be caused by this much broader and vaguer range of effects that will come from the lockdown. When we come back, how Peter Singer, a descendant of Holocaust survivors, has come to be identified with the people who carried out the Holocaust. One of these, after a moment, jumped up on the stage, ripped my glasses off my face and smashed them under his shoe. Peter Singer's life has been animated by a willingness to take ideas that lots of people believe in and then do something radical. Actually act on them. He argues that doing this,
这或许往往会促使我们倾向于支持封锁，以避免可识别原因（即病毒）造成的死亡，而不是充分权衡将要造成的死亡以及由这种更加广泛而模糊的封锁连锁反应所导致的生命质量损失。稍后回来，大屠杀幸存者的后代彼得·西格尔，是如何与那些实施大屠杀的人联系在一起的。其中一人稍后跳上舞台，扯下我脸上的眼镜并在鞋底踩碎。彼得·西格尔的人生一直受到一种意愿的推动：采用许多人信仰的理念，然后做出激进的事情。实际上采取行动。他辩称这样做，
while difficult and often running against his own feelings leads to more moral outcomes. He saw a friend make a case against factory farming and became a vegetarian. He heard about people suffering in South Asia and decided to give away a substantial amount of his income. He says that if we were willing to think about moral decisions with logic, with mathematical clarity, we may not feel better, but the results would be better. I think it is a general issue and not only related to the pandemic about what extent are we prepared to change our lives on the basis of reasoning and evidence rather than something that is emotionally appealing to us. something that is emotionally appealing to us. The other really big issue I think where this is a very serious problem is climate change, because we don't see the effects of climate change. We don't see the effects of emitting greenhouse gases.
虽然困难重重，且常常违背他自己的直觉，但却能带来更有道德的结果。他看到一位朋友反对工厂化养殖，于是成了一名素食者。他听说南亚的人民在受苦，便决定捐出自己相当大一部分收入。他说，如果我们愿意用逻辑和数学般的清晰度来思考道德决策，我们可能感觉不会更好，但结果会更好。我认为这是一个普遍的问题，不仅与大流行有关，即我们在多大程度上准备根据理性和证据来改变生活，而不是根据对我们有情感吸引力的事物来改变生活。对我们有情感吸引力的事物。我认为这是一个非常严重的问题的另一个真正巨大的领域是气候变化，因为我们看不到气候变化的影响。我们看不到排放温室气体的后果。
They're invisible, they're odorless, and we have to rely on the scientific evidence that tells us that this is contributing to climate change and this is having and will have increasingly in future a wide range of devastating effects that will cost lots of lives and cause immense hardship to a very large number of people. And we have to change our lives on the base of that. This is going to be a very bad thing for the long run, for people all over the world, and for our children and grandchildren. So I sent sort of a great paradox here, Peter, which is that you know, you're clearly someone who has reached his moral views after thinking very seriously about what is right
它们是看不见的，没有气味的，我们必须依靠科学证据来告诉我们，这正在导致气候变化，并且现在以及未来将以越来越大的规模产生广泛的破坏性影响，这将夺去大量人的生命，并给极多的人带来巨大的苦难。我们必须在此基础上改变我们的生活。从长远来看，这对世界各地的人们、对我们的子孙后代来说将是一件非常糟糕的事情。所以我在这里感觉到了一种巨大的悖论，彼得，那就是，你显然是一个在非常严肃地思考什么是对什么是错之后得出自己道德观点的人
and what is wrong. And in some ways you've grappled with these questions more seriously, probably, than most people. At the same time, as you point out, you've reached your conclusions in some ways by trying to strip away your natural emotional reaction from your moral calculations. And I'm wondering in part if this is why you sometimes might generate anger among people, You generate a lot of controversy. It's because people feel that moral judgment should be emotional. It should not be logical. I'm not sure whether people actually, it goes to the faries to say that moral judgment
什么是错。在某些方面，你对这些问题的思考可能比大多数人都要严肃。与此同时，正如你所指出的，你在某种程度上得出结论的方式，是通过试图从你的道德计算中剥离出你自然的感情反应。我在想，部分原因是否正是因为这一点，有时你可能会引起人们的愤怒，你引发了大量的争议。这是因为人们觉得道德判断应该是感性的。它不应该是逻辑的。我不确定人们是否真的，把它说成虚妄，认为道德判断
should be emotional or whether they are just feeling the emotions and that leads to the reaction. I certainly think it's true that people do feel these emotions and they have an emotional response to it to what I say and they want to cling to more widely accepted moral views which have a strong emotional basis. That as I say, it may have been formed in the past or the past of our ancestors when we lived in small face-to-face societies and we always had identified victims of anything that was wrong and now we live in a completely
应该是感性的，还是他们只是感受到了情绪，从而导致了这种反应。我当然认为确实如此，人们确实感到了这些情绪，他们对我说的话有情感上的回应，并且他们想要坚持那些有着强烈情感基础的、被更广泛接受的道德观点。正如我所说，这可能是在过去形成的，在我们生活在小型面对面社会、对任何错误的事情总是有明确识别的受害者的祖先的过去形成的，而现在我们生活在一个完全
different world, vastly larger, billions of unidentified victims. And I think often people who get upset by what I'm saying are simply giving full play to those emotions that we have as a result of our evolutionary past but that are no longer really suitable for the world today. When Peter was appointed to Princeton University in 1998, protests and blockades broke out. Many people felt it was unconscionable that Princeton would hire someone who would recommend that some severely disabled infants
不同的世界，大得多，有数十亿未被识别的受害者。我认为，经常对我的言论感到不安的人，只是在充分释放我们作为进化过去的产物而拥有、但如今已不再真正适合当今世界的情绪。1998年彼得被任命到普林斯顿大学任教时，爆发了抗议和封锁。许多人觉得普林斯顿竟然会聘用一个建议让某些严重残疾婴儿
be killed. Peter's views were compared to those of the Nazis. He was called a baby killer, and an enemy of civilization. One time at a conference in Zurich about the morality of Euthanasia, these emotions spilled out into actual violence. So I had been invited at the University of Zurich to give a lecture on my views about euthanasia for severely disabled infants
被杀死的人，这是不可理喻的。彼得的观点被拿来与纳粹相提并论。他被称作杀婴者、文明的敌人。有一次在苏黎世举行的关于安乐死道德性的会议上，这些情绪演变成了实际的暴力。所以我应苏黎世大学的邀请去就我关于严重残疾婴儿安乐死的观点发表演讲
and questions about life and death choices in medicine. And there had been some protests about those views, particularly in German speaking countries and Zurich is in a German speaking part of Switzerland. And there were a number of people with disabilities there who had been accommodated. They were in the front row in wheelchairs and they were wanting to argue with me, you know, as philosophers do, of course, that, you know, after I'd spoken, they wanted to present their objections. There were also there were groups of people in the audience who were not themselves disabled, but who identified as a political group that in German is called the Autonomon,
以及医学中生死选择的问题。对这些观点有一些抗议，特别是在德语国家，而苏黎世是瑞士德语区的一部分。那里有一些残疾人得到了妥善安排。他们坐在第一排的轮椅上，他们想和我争论，你知道的，正如哲学家们所做的那样，在我讲完之后，他们想要提出他们的反对意见。观众中还有一些人，他们自己并不是残疾人，但他们以一个政治团体的身份认同，在德语中被称为Autonomon，
essentially the autonomous ones, if you like. They kind of quasi-annicus, I suppose. They were dressed in black and they had brought a whole lot of noise making devices. And when I started speaking, they activated these noise making devices, essentially granting me hat so that it was really possible for me to speak. There was an overhead projector there, this was some time ago, it was in the pre-power point days, but there was an overhead projector there, so I used that to start writing some of the essential points since I could no longer be heard. And at that point, one of these, after a moment, jumped up on the stage, ripped my glasses off my face, I'm severely shortsighted, and smashed them under his shoe. At that point, of course, the lecturer was canceled.
本质上就是自主派，如果你愿意这么称呼的话。我想他们有点像准无政府主义者。他们身穿黑衣，带了大量制造噪音的装置。当我开始发言时，他们启动了这些噪音制造装置，本质上是想嘘我，以至于我根本无法开口说话。那里有一个投影仪，这是在一段时间以前，那还是没有PowerPoint的年代，但那里有一个投影仪，所以我开始利用它写下一些要点，因为我的声音已经听不见了。就在那时，其中一人突然跳上舞台，扯下我的眼镜——我高度近视——并在他的鞋底将其踩碎。当然，在那一点上，讲座被取消了。
I mean, it's interesting. Many people in the disability community, or at least some people in the disability community, think of you as an evil person, because you're asking these questions about how much lives are worth, and maybe lives are not all completely the same, because people have different quality of lives. I think sometimes you've even been called a Nazi, which is ironic, of course, given your own family history with the Holocaust. But I'm wondering as you hear this, do you sort of say, I understand why it is you see things this way? I do understand people's responses.
我的意思是，这很有趣。残疾人社群中的许多人，或者说残疾人社群中的某些人，认为你是一个邪恶的人，因为你在探讨这些关于生命价值多少的问题，也许生命并不完全平等，因为人们的生活质量不同。我想有时你甚至被称作纳粹，考虑到你自己的犹太人大屠杀家庭背景，这当然具有讽刺意味。但我想知道，当你听到这些时，你是否会说，我理解为什么你会有这种看法？我确实理解人们的反应。
In the case of this response specifically from German speaking countries, and as I said, remember this happened really a generation ago. I think people were trying to distance themselves from what, in many cases, their own parents had done, and perhaps had done to my grandparents during the war and they were trying to be at the opposite extreme. I think they were making a bad mistake. I think, you know, suppressing freedom of speech is one of the things that the Nazis did and that was necessary for the Nazi regime to take and retain power. So I think they were making a bad mistake about how to be a non-Nazi, but probably they thought that somehow standing up for the idea that all human life has absolutely equal value was an important way of rejecting racism.
具体就德语国家的这种反应而言，正如我所说，请记住这确实发生在整整一代人以前。我认为人们当时试图与许多情况下他们自己的父母在战争期间所做的事情（也许是对我的祖父母做过的事）划清界限，他们试图走向另一个极端。我认为他们犯了一个严重的错误。我认为，你知道，压制言论自由是纳粹所做的事情之一，这也是纳粹政权夺取并保持权力所必需的。所以我认为他们在如何成为一个非纳粹分子的问题上犯了一个严重的错误，但他们可能认为，某种程度上捍卫“所有人类生命具有绝对平等价值”这一理念是拒绝种族主义的一个重要方式。
I'm wondering as somebody who is in his 70s today, Peter, whether your own thinking about something like COVID is something that you would think about in your own life. God forbid, if you were to, if you were to fall sick, would you sort of apply the same logic to sort of how hospitals ought to treat you versus others? In other words, would you say, well, maybe the ventilator is best not used on me, but given to someone much younger? Certainly, if there's a choice between me and somebody much younger who doesn't have any underlying health conditions that mean that their life expectancy is no greater than mine, then I think it should go to the person who is younger.
我在想，作为一位如今已经70多岁的长者，彼得，你是否会将自己对新冠疫情的思考应用到你自己的生活中？上帝保佑，如果你真的生病了，你会不会把同样的逻辑应用到医院应该如何对待你与其他人的问题上？换句话说，你会不会说，好吧，也许呼吸机最好不要用在我身上，而是给更年轻的人？当然，如果在我和一个没有任何基础健康状况、寿命预期并不比我长多少的年轻人之间做选择，那么我认为应该把呼吸机给更年轻的人。
I would regret the fact that there weren't enough ventilators, and so that we couldn't boast beyond ventilators, but if it came to a choice, I hope I would have the courage to say the right thing is to give it to the 30 year old. Peter Singer, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Bray. It's been my pleasure. This week's show was produced by Paath Shah, Raina Cohen and Thomas Liu and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Engineering support from Joshua Newell. Our team includes Laura Quarelle, Kat Schuchncht and Vouchique Wabba, special thanks to Carrie Khan and Olivia Sanchez.
我会为没有足够的呼吸机而感到遗憾，从而无法让呼吸机发挥更多作用，但如果面临选择，我希望我有勇气说正确的事情是把它给30岁的人。彼得·西格尔，非常感谢您今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸。本周的节目由帕斯·沙哈、雷娜·科恩和托马斯·刘制作，由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特剪辑。工程支持来自约书亚·纽威尔。我们的团队包括劳拉·夸雷勒、卡特·舒赫特和瓦奇克·瓦巴，特别感谢卡莉·卡恩和奥利维亚·桑切斯。
Our unsung hero this week is Emily Littleton. Emily is NPR's vice president for communications. In recent weeks, she's played a pivotal role sharing information within the organization as we deal with the COVID-19 pandemic. I admire Emily because she is so devoted to her work and cares deeply about the well-being of those around her. The world could use more Emily's. Next week on the show, we continue our exploration of what it means to treat all suffering equally and consider how actions that come from a place of kindness can sometimes lead to an unjust world. I think that kind of act of helping towards people with whom we have some shared group identity
我们本周的幕后英雄是艾米丽·利特利顿。艾米丽是NPR负责传播的副总裁。在过去的几周里，在我们应对新冠肺炎大流行期间，她在组织内部共享信息方面发挥了关键作用。我钦佩艾米丽，是因为她如此投身于工作，并且深深关怀她身边的每一个人。这个世界需要更多的艾米丽。下周的节目中，我们将继续探讨如何平等对待所有苦难的意义，并思考那些源于善意的行为有时如何会导致一个不公正的世界。我认为这种向我们具有某种共同群体认同的人提供帮助的行为
is really the modern way in which discrimination likely happens. You can find more hidden brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like today's show, please consider sharing it with your friends. Afterwards, set up a video chat with them to debate the moral issues raised in this conversation. I'm Shankar Vedantumım ve bu, NPR'nin There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
确实是现代社会中歧视可能发生的常见方式。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请考虑与你的朋友分享。之后，与他们建立视频聊天，辩论这次对话中提出的道德问题。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来发表评论。